right time for some throwback thursday
vegas edition
jc has more in this week's sin city
chronicles
it's time for this week's sin city
chronicles a weekly look back at vegas
history
and happenings mandalay bay opened on
march 2nd 1999
festivities included a parade of 200
motorcycles
with dan aykroyd john goodman and jim
belushi of the blues brothers
being the grand marshals and bob dylan
performed at the house of blues
[Music]
some interesting facts the original name
of the property was going to be the
paradise hotel
and pavarotti opened the resorts event
center
and pavarotti also was the first
classical act
to perform at the thomas and mack and
that was on march 3rd 1985.
now march 2009 the m resort opened
4 000 invited guests filled the casino
and watched fireworks and a fire and
water show
by the pool nascar is at the speedway
this weekend
jeff gordon will be in the booth calling
the action but it was
20 years ago on march 4th 2001 that
gordon won the big race at the las vegas
motor speedway
dean martin debuted his solo show at the
sands on march 6
1957. look at these photos his show only
went 38 minutes
but it was a hit martin was signed to a
five-year deal
and was paid 25 000 a week
and after the show martin would often
head to the casino floor to deal
blackjack
i'm not sure if that would actually fly
today and finally if you grew up in las
vegas
you probably at some point went to
disney on ice
march 1st 1984 the first ice show was
held at the thomas and mack
it was called walt disney's world on ice
ice odyssey
and that's your sin city chronicles for
the first week of march